N
THE LEFT TOO TIMID AT A MOMENT
OF GREAT CONSEQUENCE WITH THAT
START WITH OUR PANEL EXPANDED
TONIGHT.
FOX NEWS SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST BRIT HUME.
BEN DOMENECH PUBLISHER OF THE
PUBLISHER.
TREY GOWDY AND HAROLD FORD JR.
CEO OF EMPOWERMENT AND UP
COLLUSION CAPITAL.
BRIT, LET ME START WITH YOU.
IT SEEMS LIKE ALWAYS SPEAKER
PELOSI HAS PULLED A RABBIT OUT
OF THE HAT WHEN IT COMES TO
LEGISLATION.
THESE MAJORITIES ARE SLIM FOR
DEMOCRATS.
TIED ESSENTIALLY IN THE SENATE
AND ONLY 4 IN THE HOUSE.
ALMOST LIKE A HEAVY LIFT WHAT WE
ARE HEARING SO FAR.
>> YEAH, IT DOES, BRET.
I THINK ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS
THEY ARE RUNNING INTO WITH THIS
MASSIVE BILL ARE A FUNCTION OF
TRYING TO ACT AS IF YOU HAVE A
MASSIVE MANDATE WHEN YOU HAVE
BASICALLY NO MANDATE AT ALL.
I MEAN, THIS IS REALLY -- THEY
REALLY HAVE A STAGGERINGLY
AMBITIOUS SPENDING AGENDA.
ALSO SOCIAL AGENDA WITH, YOU
KNOW, TIED SENATE AND A TINY
HANDFUL OF VOTES, YOU KNOW,
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE.
>> IT WAS PROBABLY NEVER GOING
TO WORK AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS
NOT GOING TO WORK.
THE DECISION BY THE 9
PARLIAMENTARIAN WAS OBVIOUS AND
OBVIOUSLY CORRECT.
THOUGH I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE.
BIG BILL, NO MANDATE.
>> Bret: WHERE DOES THIS GO?
I MEAN, YOU HAVE GOT THE HOUSE
ESSENTIALLY HOLDING THE OTHER
BILL, THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE HOSTAGE UNTIL
THEY DEAL WITH THE 3.5 TRILLION
OR AT LEAST THAT'S HOW IT SETS
UP RIGHT NOW.
>> I THINK THIS IS LOOKING LIKE
A ROLLING DISASTER AND IT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, GIVEN THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS REALLY ONLY GOING
TO GET ONE BITE AT THE APPLE
HERE.
IT'S KIND OF THE SKIPPING THE
STEP.
HOW MANY LICKS DOES IT TAKE TO
GET TO THE CENTER OF THE TOOTSIE
POP.
UNFORTUNATELY HERE BY TRYING TO
CRAM SO MUCH INTO THIS PACKAGE
THEY HAVE CREATED A SCENARIO
WHERE THERE ARE MANY MODERATES,
NOT JUST THE ONES WE KNOW ABOUT
PUBLICLY WHO ARE NOT GOING TO GO
ALONG WITH SOMETHING THIS
MASSIVE AND THE OTHER SIDE AS
YOU SUGGESTED, THE LEFT IS
REALLY NOT SATISFIED WITH THIS.
IT DOESN'T DO AS MUCH AS THEY
WANT IT TO DO.
SO I THINK, UNFORTUNATELY, THIS
THING IS ROLLING TOWARDS REALLY
HARD BRICK WALL POLITICALLY AND
IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE THE
LAST MAJOR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THEY ARE ABLE TO GET THROUGH OR
GET TO THIS POINT BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS.
>> Bret: YEAH, SPEAKING OF WHICH
SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS TALKING
ABOUT THIS BILL.
>> THE 3.5 TRILLION IS MUCH TOO
LOW, A COMPROMISE HAS ALREADY
BEEN MADE AN AGREEMENT HAS BEEN
MADE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, BY THE WAY,
POLL AFTER POLL AFTER POLL ARE
TELLING US NOW IS THE TIME TO
STAND UP TO POWERFUL SPECIAL
INTEREST.
NOW IS THE TIME TO START
REPRESENTING WORKING FAMILIES.
ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES.
>> Bret: NOW, SENATORS MANCHIN
AND SINEMA AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED, HAROLD, ARE THE ONES
TAKING THE PROGRESSIVE FIRE BUT
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH THIS AND NOT JUST
THE OVER ALL PRICE TAG.
>> SO, GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
I THINK DEMOCRATS IN THE
CONGRESS HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
FOR 40 YEARS DEMOCRATS
CONTROLLED THE CONSCIOUS UNTIL
'94, NEWT GINGRICH AND CONGRESS
BROUGHT IN A REVOLUTION.
OVER THE LAST 2 YEARS, THE
COUNTRY HAS ENAMORED THEMSELVES
WITH WANTING RESULTS.
AND CHANGED THE MAJORITY FOUR
TIMES.
DEMOCRATS IN THE MAJORITY NOW.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD TAKE THE
VICTORY THAT'S IN FRONT OF THEM.
IT'S TIME TO RESET HERE.
I LISTENED TO LIBERALS.
I LISTENED TO THE MODERATES.
BUT, MORE IMPORTANTLY, I
LISTENED TO THE COUNTRY, JOE
BIDEN WAS ELECTED TO UNIFY THE
COUNTRY AND HELP STABLIZE AND
BRING US AROUND AN AGENDA THAT
COULD ADVANCE THE COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS WOULD BE GOOD TO LOOK
TO THAT.
AND ONCE YOU GET A VICTORY, THEN
YOU FIGURE OUT THE NEXT VICTORY.
BUT, DEMOCRATS, LIBERAL AND
MODERATE ALIKE SHOULD REALIZE
YOU COULD LOSE THIS MAJORITY AND
YOU WOULD DESERVE IT IF YOU
DON'T TAKE THE VICTORY RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU AND LIVE TO FIGHT
AND ADVANCE ANOTHER DAY.
>> Bret: TREY, YOU HAVE SEEN
SPEAKER PELOSI DO THESE
LEGISLATIVE THING WHERE SHE
HERDS THE CATS AND SOMEHOW
MANAGES TO GET THE VOTES ON
THESE BIG PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
AS I SAID WITH BRIT, IT SEEMS
LIKE THEY'RE HEADING TOWARDS A
CORNER HERE.
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU, BRIT,
SHE AIN'T GOING TO HERD KYRSTEN
SINEMA AND JOE MANCHIN, SHE
MAYBE CAN GET HOUSE IN ORDER.
I GUARANTEE SHE WILL NOT GET
SENATOR SINEMA IN ORDER.
HAROLD IS RIGHT IT'S A 50/50
COUNTRY.
BERNIE SANDERS WAS TOO CRAZY TO
BE THE NOMINEE OF THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
WHY WOULD THE ENTIRE COUNTRY LET
HIM SET THE AGENDA?
IT'S A NARROW MAJORITY.
AND REPUBLICANS WOULD BE WISE TO
ASK WHY IS ELIZABETH McDONOUGH
HAVING TO SAVE THE REPUBLIC
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T WIN A SENATE
SEAT IN GEORGIA, THAT'S WHY.
>> Bret: THEN YOU HAVE THE
SET-UP FOR THIS RALLY THIS
WEEKEND AND YOU JUST HEARD
HOWIE'S PIECE BUT TAKE A LISTEN
TO THIS MEDIA BUILD UP.
>> WASHINGTON ON HIGH ALERT
AHEAD OF A RALLY SUPPORTING
RIOTERS ARRESTED IN THE CAPITOL
ATTACK.
>> WARNINGS OF A SERIOUS SET THE
VIOLENCE IN TOMORROW'S RALLY IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IN SUPPORT OF THE CAPITOL
INSURRECTION NIST OF.
>> THE MOST UNKNOWN TONIGHT IS
WHAT TOMORROW MAY BRING.
>> AUTHORITIES WARNING OF
THREATS OF VIOLENCE AND
CONCERNING CHATTER ON THE EVE OF
A RALLY IN SUPPORT OF HUNDRED
PEOPLE NOW CHARGED IN THE
JANUARY 6TH RIOT.
>> IT WAS A FAIRLY PALTRY TURN
OUT FOR THE JUSTICE FOR
JANUARY 6TH RALLY.
THEY SAID MAYBE 700 WOULD SHOW
IT PRETTY MUCH FIZZLED.
>> Bret: BRIT, WHAT ABOUT THIS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> LOOK, THIS IS THE CASE OF THE
AUTHORITIES IN WASHINGTON HAVING
FAILED TO PREPARE FOR THE
JANUARY 6TH RALLY HAVING DECIDED
THEY WEREN'T GOING TO MAKE THAT
MISTAKE AGAIN.
AS I SAID MILITARY GENERALS THEY
ARE ALWAYS FIGHTING THE LAST
WAR.
I GUESS YOU COULD SAY THE SAME
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
OVER THE WEEKEND.
WAR WHAT THEY GOT WAS SOME PAIL
IMITATION OF THAT PATHETIC
LITTLE PALTRY TURNOUT
UNSUPPORTED BY MOST
CONSERVATIVING ORGANIZATIONS.
>> Brit: THERE WERE AROUND 30
PHOTOGRAPHERS AROUND ONE GUY
WITH A FLAG.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, THE FIRST RALLY
WAS A CRIMINAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL DISASTER.
SO I'M NOT SURPRISED THAT PEOPLE
DIDN'T SHOW UP FOR THE SECOND
ONE.
THE SILVER LINING IS THE MEDIA
WAS THERE, WHICH MEANS THEY
WEREN'T AT THE -- AND THEY
WEREN'T IN A MASKLESS INDOOR
ENVIRONMENT AND THEY GOT TO MEET
SOME COPS BEFORE THEY'RE
DEFUNDED.
THAT'S THE SILVER LINING.
>> Bret: HERE IS PETER DOOCY AND
JEN PSAKI ON THIS BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT THE BORDER.
>> IS SOMEBODY ASKING THE
FOREIGN NATIONALS WHO ARE
WALKING IN DEL RIO, TEXAS AND
SETTING UP CAMPS ON THIS SIDE OF
THE BORDER FOR PROOF OF
VACCINATION OR A NEGATIVE COVID
TEST?
>> AS INDIVIDUALS COME ACROSS
THE BORDER, AND THEY ARE BOTH
ASSESSED FOR WHETHER THEY HAVE
ANY SYMPTOMS, IF THEY HAVE
SYMPTOMS THE INTENTION IS FOR
THEM TORE QUARANTINED.
THAT IS OUR PROCESS.
THEY ARE NOT INTENDING TO STAY
HERE FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD OF
TIME I DON'T THINK IT'S THE SAME
THING.
IT'S NOT THE SAME THING.
WE ARE EXPELLING INDIVIDUALS
BASED ON TITLE 42.
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF COVID.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
SO, HAROLD, THEY ARE NOT
EXPECTING TO STAY FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME.
WELL, THEY ARE HOPING.
TO SAY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY DOWN
IN DEL RIO, TEXAS TODAY WHAT DO
YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> THAT YOUNG DOOCY KNOWS HOW TO
DISH OUT A DOOCY THERE.
I THINK THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE IN A PICKLE ON
THIS ONE.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET BETTER
CONTROL OF THE BORDER.
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN ALIKE
DON'T QUITE UNDERSTAND THE
RULES.
I THINK AT SOME POINT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
CONSIDER CHANGES IN HOW
PERSONNEL AND OTHER THINGS HOW
YOU THINK ABOUT THE GOVERNING
AND THE GUIDANCE DOWN THERE.
JEH JOHNSON WHO COMES ON THIS
NETWORK AND OTHER NETWORKS AND
GIVES A PRETTY GOOD TAKE ON
THINGS.
I WOULD SAY THOUGH IF PRESS
OVERHYPE STOP VIOLENCE WE OUGHT
TO SEND THEM TO PHILLY L.A. AND
NEW YORK OVERNIGHT.
>> Bret: BEN, 10 SECONDS HERE?
>> THE IDEA THAT INTENTION IS
DOING A LOT OF WORK IN THAT JEN
PSAKI RESPONSE RIGHT THERE WHICH
IS NOT BEING DELIVERED WHEN IT
DOCUMENTS ACTUAL BORDER POLICY
AND PRACTICE.
>> Bret: AND LET ME JUST SAY
THAT MANNY P